Kasey's with us in Fort Worth Texas hey
Casey welcome the Dave Ramsey show hey
thanks so much for taking my call Dave
it's an honor to speak to you today you
too what's up hey I've got a situation I
need your advice on I'm a longtime
listener and I'm having problems with my
father he followed bankruptcy in 2013
and is on this he was on this great path
you know he went through SPU and
everything but now she's back into
credit cards he's back into making these
terrible that you're making these
terrible choices and now I'm in college
and he's asking me for money and trying
to fund his bad habits and how long I am
18 and like that's so sad how
dysfunctional and screwed up is this
yeah and even worse is he wouldn't went
and cashed out his whole life policy at
his age and now he can't get any more
insurance and he has about $15,000 in
debt and so when he passes on I'm gonna
have to take care of that I need your
advice
and so what to do because I'm kind of
stuck I'm so sorry your dad's a guy like
that I know that was being nice I can't
that's just awful that's why it's hard
for you it's really hard for you here's
the thing - you're 18 freaking years old
your own man should not ask you for
anything that's completely out of line
it's completely out of line it's so
pitiful it's unbelievable and as crazy
as it sounds in your mind it sounds
triple crazy to me that he wouldn't do
that that he would then that he would
get that he would be that that twisted
up and screwed up now your job is not to
fix him that's his job he's supposed to
be a grown man and we're gonna fix
himself you can't you can't tell people
what to do you already know what he's
supposed to be doing
you've already at 18 years old
identified several things that he should
be doing that he's an
and he hadn't figured that out at his
age no you've got to just be kind and
very firm it's your dad
so we'll honor his position of
fatherhood but we will not honor his
behaviors okay you can honor your father
and mother you know the Bible says honor
your father mother
you can honor your father and mother
without honoring their misbehavior yeah
and so I honor the position but I'm not
honoring the behavior no you're not
giving him any money and the problem is
you're tempted I can hear it you really
want to give him advice he's not going
to take your advice you just you know
what I wouldn't just say dad go back to
the FPU I can't help you that I'm an 18
year old college student you shouldn't
even be asking me that's just wrong go
back to fvu thats ought to be your
answer
dad really dads don't do this they don't
ask 18 year old sons for their help who
are in college you shouldn't be doing
this you should be an FPU straightening
your life out I can't help you I'm so
sorry dad and the answer is no no no and
the problem is anybody that but even ask
this it's not gonna hear the note so
you're gonna have to tell me more than
once
you can do it kindly and calmly and very
firmly and you have to Casey you have to
this is toxic and dysfunctional is crap
[Music]